he is the stanford football coach the
head coach
david shaw back here on the show how are
you david
i'm great rich especially now that i
know we're gonna play football excellent
okay let's get into that right away
um you were on about a month ago and i
asked you if you thought that
the decision to postpone was the right
one you said unequivocally
um what what changed david
a great question multiple things changed
um first of all
we were looking we were testing once a
week and it was going well
we were looking into increasing that to
three times a week
and there were still gaps you know when
you test three times a week there's
still
a gap in there and we were looking at
what the nfl was doing testing daily and
we didn't know if that was going to be a
possibility for us
um the earliest we had heard was
probably november
so pushing the season back to january
made a lot of sense
if we started testing daily sometime
november december
and then getting ready to go in january
that way we could be
have so much more certainty that
everybody that crossed those lines to
get on the field
was going to be virus free on top of
that we all saw the article that came
out on the heart abnormality
our doctors were concerned about that
and are to a certain degree
uh still um but the fact that it's now
it's been proven extremely rare um which
we knew the possibility early on but we
were operating with a lot of caution
um it's very rare and we now know how we
have to
study the heart and take care of the
heart and test for the heart
any time anybody that is that it is
catching the virus so now we feel a lot
better about our process it's a lot
better about that heart
abnormality and with our new deal with
clyde l we can test daily now
so that now set up our process to get
back and play football sooner than we
so so are you testing players daily
right now is that happening already or
when does that happen if not
no we've got the testing machines in
every every team in our conference does
now
our people are training on them and the
goal was to be ready for
the start of training camp in a couple
of weeks to start testing every single
day
coaches staff and our student athletes
so you're more comfortable
because again you you're not just a head
coach here or in a molder of men and
also a caretaker of men
but you were also uh highly involved
with
the science of it and the conversation
uh with dr
hainleine who's the chief medical
officer of the ncaa you were locked in
on
those discussions uh are you so you're
more comfortable now than the last time
we spoke about five weeks ago that's
what you're saying
yes i'm on the pac-12 covid working
group as well as the ncaa
kobit working group and those are the
conversations
just feeling so much better about the
science we knew the science was going to
catch up there's so many people around
the world
working on fighting this this virus we
knew the science is going to catch up
there are a lot of companies out there
doing a lot of things to prepare
themselves for
not just finding a vaccine but better
treatment
and how we can handle this virus and
detecting the virus we're so much better
now
three weeks later four weeks later than
we were before in particular with this
uh company crydel that's come in and
made a deal with our
our conference to be able to have rapid
testing
that way we can test that day and know
that day that you don't have the virus
so now we can resume football activities
now we're still working with our
our county um fine-tuning all the
details we're not there yet
but the bottom line our guys are in our
guys are working out our guys are
working hard
and preparing for a season that is right
around the corner david shaw stanford
university head football coach here on
the rich eisen show and before we get to
the
uh immediate future i still just want to
if you don't mind linger
over the last five weeks and some of the
narratives that have been
uh discussed nationally here and placed
them before you for
a response the first being is that the
pac-12
was the last to do it uh to
sort of um get back into uh
a football season earlier than expected
because of the pressure placed upon it
uh by other conferences not pushing at
all and the big ten
saying that they were coming back what
do you say to that coach
well you know um i'm used to people
disparaging us that don't live on the
west coast that kind of happens
all the time um i do believe
and wholeheartedly and would have would
have absolutely supported
um not coming back earlier if we didn't
have this testing deal
what we've seen across the country
schools being shut down programs being
shut down
schools that are doing the best job they
can i i will never point the finger into
anybody
i know they're doing the best job if
they can um
testing once a week twice a week with so
many student athletes that not just
interact on campus but interact in their
communities
we didn't feel it was good enough and
honestly we've been proven right um
they're places that are doing a great
job and student athletes that are
working really hard
but if you're not testing daily you're
not testing more frequently
um you're going to have those outbreaks
that have happened all over the country
with
it was programs being shut down for for
a week plus
with um with schools that brought
student athletes
the students back and then sent them
back home this is a difficult thing and
and
we don't take it lightly our university
presidents have not taken it lightly
so we were going to follow the science
we were going to do this if this made
sense
and with this new deal the test daily
now it makes a lot more sense for us
to accelerate we weren't going to be
pressured by the big 10 and we weren't
going to be pressured by
what other people were doing i've said
this before and i'll say it again i
could honestly look my guys in the eye
and say we're looking out for your
health
and welfare and that's why we're making
the decisions that we're making
yeah and i guess you kind of touched
upon uh the other narrative
coach that i'm sure um rankles
uh that there wasn't uh enough push
uh by the fan base or the by the parent
base in the pac-12 in the same way that
we saw on the big ten because there's
not nearly as much enthusiasm
out in pac-12 country i placed that one
before you too
david shaw yeah
um people will make whatever narratives
they want
which is fine no one can look me in the
eye and tell me that our student
athletes
don't work as hard as anybody else in
america that they don't care as much as
anybody else in america that their
parents
don't care about them and their health
and welfare as well as their
future prospects in the nfl um that's
that that just doesn't make sense to us
now what makes sense to me is our
process
our process from the very beginning and
i can speak very intelligently on this
because as i said i was involved in this
process of
being on this on this working group and
we heard from the doctors and we kept
our students and our
and their parents informed of our entire
process from the very beginning
they're going to follow the doctor's
recommendations we're not going to be
swayed by politics we're not going to be
swayed by
what other conferences do we have
medical experts that we're going to talk
to we're going to communicate with
other place other people around the
country as well as people of the cdc and
different places
to make sure that we're doing what we
believe is is best
um and best for our student athletes
we're not going to put football ahead of
their health
that's just not going to happen so the
fact that we didn't
um have a lot of marches and all those
things for me
you just said we did a great job of
keeping everybody informed of our
process we kept everybody informed of
what we were doing and why
um we had for a while we had weekly
meetings with our head coaches in our
conference
to let them know what the doctors are
saying we met periodically with our
athletic director so we're all on the
same page
our university uh presidents met with
our doctors and our university
um our athletic directors um so
i think we were all on the same page
this entire time
um and now the what's once the science
found
an option for us and now an option to
come back and play we followed that
we didn't follow pressure from anybody
else um understood how some people felt
um but you know fan bases and all those
things hey those are all great
those are all great but we're going to
follow our doctors and our doctors
have not come back to us and said hey
with this daily testing with where the
heart abnormality is
we feel comfortable coming back our
president's deliberated about it
and said you know what we feel good
about following this process and coming
back and now we want to give ourselves a
little bit of a runway
um to get our guys back because a lot of
us you know we're a quarter system a lot
of us sent our guys home
they worked extremely hard for the
summer we gave them a couple weeks off
to go
to go back home and rest and now that we
changed the calendar again
now we're getting them back and we need
some time to get them ready to play some
good football
head football coach at stanford
university a few more minutes left here
with david shaw let's talk about the
here and now uh david when do we see a
schedule when do you see a schedule when
does that hit uh
we'll see i know it's being worked on in
a dark room someplace
and hoping to hoping to hear something
about that
uh possibly by this weekend we're all
waiting to hear it um
bottom line for us is we're getting our
guys ready we start training camp in a
couple of weeks
so we're getting our guys bodies ready
um for this ridiculous sport that we all
love
um but uh at some point we'll we'll see
when
all i know is i know five of our
opponents because we're playing the
packs over north you know the only
question is whether or not it's
what school is going to be and it's from
the fact 12 south so we've got a good
idea and get started all those teams
um and we'll wait to hear hopefully this
weekend who we play and in terms of the
splits home and away
do you have any sense of that because
obviously when you
it it's got nothing to do with fans uh
but it does
maybe other places could have fans and
then obviously traveling
um in in the uh pandemic is definitely
a disadvantage for those who just show
up on campus
i imagine right yeah yeah traveling
takes takes some effort because
um there have been a lot of reports of
people contracting the virus whether
they travel
alone or travel with a team so a lot of
care needs to go into
how you take buses how you fly and how
you take the next bus and then how you
operate in a hotel and team meals and
all those things
um so yeah where you play is is
important
once again i think we have an idea that
our divisional opponents
will be switching back and forth every
year like we did we're opposite of what
we did last year i think we have an idea
that that's going to happen
um and then where we play our other game
we'll see
um but yeah those are things that our
operations people have been working on
honestly since this whole thing began
and then in terms of your um you know in
terms of the here and now as well
uh your former quarterback who
transferred uh
to mississippi state kj costello what a
dynamite start it was for
him and huge win um for
for for him personally i'd love to give
you the floor and give
know what your thoughts were on on all
of that
coach i i'm so proud of kj i
i have a special relationship with him
and his family um
i loved him dearly i hated to see him go
understood his reasons for being a grad
transfer
whether we had two phenomenal
quarterbacks kj made his choice and i
supported his choice 100
we all knew he was going to go out there
and put on the show kj had a rough year
his last year with us
um you know couldn't get who can help
he's healthy for one game and was
phenomenal
against arizona but that was really the
only game he was healthy all year
um it hurt him so much it hurt me so
much and all of us
because we thought he was capable of the
year before
his junior year with us he did the 3 500
yards second most
yardage in the history of stanford
football and 2 for 29 touchdowns
so we knew this guy had a chance to be a
superstar in college
and a superstar potentially in the nfl
so not surprised he goes into a mike
leach system and throws for a ton of
yards
mike's had a lot of quarterbacks he's
had very few we've got
like guys guys like kj with the arm and
the top that he's got
um so i know he's going to put up big
yards and i hope they win a bunch of
games and then lastly
um you know if you would put your your
draft evaluator hat back on
if we did have uh a draft show together
like normal
we would have been all over your
evaluation of justin herbert
and i think we've i've even gotten it
from you uh in past
uh appearances here on this show but now
he got in there
uh he's gotten in there for two games
and the first star he gets he's told
literally at the coin toss that he's
going in
i mean talk about adversity um i don't
know how much you've been able to to
spot of him so far but your your two
cents on on his first couple games
well first of all to evaluate justin
it's nice a little background on him
he's a hometown kid
from eugene oregon who was under
recruited
so he's got no issues kind of being the
the guy with a chip on his shoulder
being the guy that people don't talk
about
um he's had to battle the fight and
scrap to get on the field
this kid's got talent he's got size he's
got a repeatable arm motion
he's got strong arm you know the only
negative anybody's ever really had on
every once in a while and sometimes you
see you see a lot of touch and sometimes
you don't see him truly drive the ball
now can he drive the ball 100 absolutely
he threw one of the most beautiful balls
i've ever seen
i think it was maybe his junior year
against uh washington state i think it
was
where the ball was it was an aaron
rodgers off his back foot 40 yard bomb
in the back of the end zone
so this guy's got all kinds of talent um
he's just getting started
um excited to see where he is right now
i think he's got great tools there with
a good friend of mine
hamilton's a quarterback coach this kid
got a chance to be a star in the nfl
now if the jets called you up david
shawn this had nothing to do with you
being a coach
please that's not that's not the way i'm
walking in here that's not the way i'm
walking in here
if the jets called you up and said help
us with sam darnold right now
what what two cents would you give
because you you were very
high on him when we were sitting in
dallas texas that night on that draft
set
and what is going on with him is nothing
short of
patently disappointing what would you do
what would you counsel the jets to do
that is a that is a bigger question um i
think than than your time your show has
time for
i would say this i would say this yes um
there's a quote that
that came to me actually when i was
watching i didn't watch the the jeff's
game i watched the highlights of the
quote that that steve young said years
ago
they said the quarterback is the most
dependent position on the
on the team and when you get a young
quarterback in there
and if they don't experience success
it's hard to find success
and uh when you talk about offensive
line or having not enough weapons or
having a running game or having a tight
end like all those things that we think
can help
a young quarterback develop those things
haven't materialized
there now the great ones absolutely the
great ones they will elevate everybody
that's there
um i believe the kid's got talent i
think he's got a quick release and an
accurate you think he's an accurate
pastor i think he's a better athlete
than people give him credit for he made
an unbelievable throw going from his
left
going back to his right um the other
week that was that was outstanding
but that being said this is a results
game and if you don't have the guys as a
quarterback you still have to find a way
to at the very least be successful
individually and then secondly also try
to
have that lead your team to success and
that just hasn't happened it has not
at all but what about josh allen how
about that kid huh
i mean he's taken an mvp step forward so
far
this year yeah um you know and to me has
a little bit in common with with justin
herbert
um just the the size and athleticism and
they can see over everybody and he's got
guys in his face he can make awkward
body throws
um the big thing for me and the nfl for
those guys that are
as brian dilke's called above the line
they're going to make five throws a game
that the regular human beings can't make
and josh allen has that kind of talent
coach thanks again for calling in um
and and always you know um being honest
and spitting truth and telling us what's
on your mind
and good luck i hope you get that
schedule sooner rather than later
and let's talk as you get ready for the
season and i'm glad that you're back
playing
football big time sounds good thanks
rich right back at you that's david shaw
of stanford
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here